la teacher strike ended this week here
here in Los Angeles an agreement was
reached in the teacher strike and
teachers are just now getting back to
work and it's great news for one of our
audience members who's an LA teacher her
name is Angela Flores and she's one of
those straight shootin teachers from a
tough inner city high school who tells
it like it is you know the type hello
there Angela hey Chuck chill out do you
want to die out there with your homeboys
or you want to try in here with your
home work you like guns
where's a shot straight to your dome yes
to the main that kid is laughing at her
anyway I always appreciate our
hard-working teachers so thank you very
much miss Flores we're gonna move it on
now
hey JJ fad you like raps I'm about to
bust a rhyme that just might save your
life mommy violence and sirens out there
in the hood but schools on fleek and
according to my nephew bleak means good
word do your future
anyway very powerful stuff miss Flores
thanks for your inspiring words moving
on with the show what what Oh God
[Music]
hey Wayne Bobby
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey John Wayne Bobbit I'm about to drop
some knowledge on you like that lady
dropped her dick in a ditch
oops I meant penis instead of smoking
Sherman [ __ ] why don't you
dissect some worms and stare back in the
classroom you might like what you see
vato your future
walking in a city tasteful titre Angela
Flores everybody
I think she just she just turned around
a member of Lynyrd Skynyrd no no one
watching at home will believe us that
guy is not an actor he's not